abone ol
bu maden dostum bir kimi konuşuyoruz Ben
bu konuşmama bünyesinde görev aldığım
gençlik görme eklenmesinin kuruluş
felsefesini ve aynı zamanda çevre
gönüllüsü olmadığında tazesini
yanıklarında düşündüğüm iki hikaye Katkı
sağlamak istiyoruz
bu hikaye lerimizden Birincisinde 4
temel aktörümüz var Nedir bu dört
traktör
e Herkese birisi
da herhangi biri ve hiç kimse
abone ol
O bizim yapılması gereken önemli bir şey
ortaya çıkıyor
ve herkes birisini bu işi yapacağın
atayım
Aslında herhangi birinin yapıp
yapabileceği bir iş ama hiç kimse bu
içecek Maya yanaşmayın ca Dolayısıyla iş
yapamıyorum
iyi birisi Ama bu iş Herkes bir şeydi
diyoruz kızarak cevap verince herkes
herhangi birinin bu işi yapabileceğini
düşünüyorum hiç kimseye ise bu işi
herkesin yapabileceğini düşünüyorum
en sonunda ne olduğunu merak ediyorsunuz
gözlerinizden görüyorum herhangi birinin
yapabileceği bir işi hiç kimse
yapmadığım için herkes birinizi sürüyor
var ama Dolayısıyla işimize yapılmamış
olarak kılıyorum
ve benzeri hikaye daha devam etmek
istiyorum
Bu yaşlı bir hocamız var
bu sabaha karşı uyanıyor hava almak için
de Güneşin doğuşunu keyfini çıkarmak
için sahile geliyor şöyle yaklaştığı
zaman ilerden birini görüyor biraz daha
yaklaşır bunu bir çocuk olduğunu fark
ediyor Biraz daha fazla uzaklaştıktan
sonra
bu kişinin Beni siz kenarına kıyıya
vurmuş olan deniz yıldızlarını okyanusa
bıraktığını görüyor Sonra çocuğa
yaklaşıyor neden Deniz yıldızların
Okyanusu atıyorsun diye cevabı
söylüyorum
o çocuk güneş yükseldi mi havalar
ısınıyor onları Deniz atmasın
susuzluktan ölecek yer diyor
adamsa sahip piramitler kilometrelerce
uzanıyor binlerce Deniz Yıldızı var
Hangi birini atacaksın Ne fark edecek
gibi alaylı bir şekilde cevap veriyor
Aynı bu herkes herhangi bir kimse
hiçbiri hikayemizdeki olduğu gibi
o
çocuk adamı dinledikten sonra biraz
sessiz kalıyor adamı bakıyor sonra yerde
ne tane deniz yıldızında alıyor Bunu
elinde tutarak adama diyor ki bu Deniz
Yıldızı için fark edecek işte sonra
alıyor onu da Deniz okyanusun
derinliklerine bırakayım
o çocuk kendine düşen görevi yaptı
Kısacası fark yaratmak istersek
yaratırız Yeter ki sen sana düşeni
Selam
arkadaşlar Benim sunumum burada bitmedi
sayın seyirciler dinleyiciler Ben de
bize düşen görev yapalım diye bir ufak
bir oyunla birlikte size bir harekete
geçirmek istiyorum hep birlikte Sen sana
düşeni yap dememizi istiyorum
O bir saniye Öncelikle ben söyleyeyim
ardından hep birlikte Sen sana düşeni
yap değil alkışlayalım olur mu
3-2-1 Sen sana bir şey yazdım ben sana
şekerim şim